on this episode I don't let Felicity get
away with it you ask questions and I
answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is some 99 of the askgaryvee
show before we start
follow me d-roc just follow me d rock
because we just got to take care of some
business
yep yep yep yep Felicity I'm using you
as an example and what many may not know
is Felicity was sitting a couple seats
over she didn't want to be in the shot
so let this be a lesson to everybody
who's gonna run away if you run from the
camera the camera will find you but
let's say the camera finding you all
right we can go back that was fun
so good that was good tone setter that's
right Steve keep your [ __ ] together
Steve if you run from the camera the
camera will find it you hi I'm ready it
was a good start feeling feeling a solid
beginning to the show
all right Jarrod asks where's blogging
at these days I feel like it's not as
popular as it was a number of years ago
Jarrod good question about blogging
block you know what's happened with
blogging is blogging is massively
important it's just not the thing that
people talk about not only that blogging
became so big it became the
establishment I mean like if you have a
website and you're putting out content
on it you're blogging and what has also
happened is that social networking has
in theory become the micro version of
that blogging and so now everybody in
theory as a matter of fact Twitter was
flat-out known as a micro blogging
platform for many Zak can you show
thanks I thought you were hacking the
show right like you put them on knowing
I would respond to that and then get on
camera got okay okay cool that was
amazing Twitter was known as I michael
micro blogging platforms so I think
Facebook and Instagram and and you know
medium there's platforms that now people
are using because what people start
understanding was they want exposure if
you're blogging you want to talk to the
world what people aren't as good at that
at is actually getting people then to
come and see that they were relying on
you know SEO back in the day and things
of that nature where people realize is
that people are living in Instagram and
in Pinterest and then
Facebook and in Twitter and so they're
now going to the people and blogging
their you know telling a story in your
home when nobody's there is quite lonely
and not that interesting that was what
what happened to a lot of people in the
blogging sphere whereas you know going
to Town Hall and getting on there and
grabbing a mic and talking maybe some
people will listen but maybe that person
was better everybody's talking
everyone's listening so it's just the
evolution the thesis of people wanting
to communicate on the internet hasn't
changed the formation of the the way
it's looked at the terminology we use
the new core you know Riccar nation of
it is just what you're living in right
now
sound space asks my business is
completely digital focused on exclusive
and shareable content how important or
real-life meetings sounds face to me
real-life meanings matter because human
beings make all decisions right like so
far thank god the robots haven't taken
over but it's coming but you know
hopefully i don't think i'll see it but
it's coming and so while that's still
the case
real-life meetings matter because
there's just so much context that can be
done in human interaction that doesn't
happen over digital you can't map
everything i feel plenty of emotions
over twitter and things of that nature
but the energy in the room is lost right
like the energy in the room is lost and
so to me that is the that is the part
that matters so much in the equation of
real life to me i always say that
digital is a gateway drug take him
digital is the gateway drug to the human
interaction you know as a matter of fact
it's funny not andrew who didn't know
who the [ __ ] I was but a lot of the
people here on the team and Zach but a
lot of people here on the team didn't
know who I was
you know there was a gateway drug
happening before they got here which
created context but then meaning in real
life takes it to a whole nother level
you could work for the company and they
have a whole different context when
you're on the team you know what I mean
Frank asks how did you meet Willie
Morris and what attracted you to
faithbox
Frankie you know Willie faithbox I'm an
early early angel investor true angel
investor in birth Birchbox and barkbox
and believe in the box of the month
business model especially when you layer
media on top of it which those companies
have done well I really wanted to be in
that space and really thought of like
where's the biggest open space what's a
big business to be in in the box space
and you know and religion is a big
business and so I thought that was
fascinating it was in back in my mind it
was brainstorming it Bill Toronto who's
a principal at a vayner/rse was you know
aware of Willie through maybe a
girlfriends girlfriend friend he was
leaving Amazon coming to New York I take
a lot of serendipitous meetings we sat
down we hit it off I thought he had the
right makeup I had great hair and and we
made the move it was really that's about
it wasn't super complicated you know had
an idea got to know him a little bit
there were some correlations on passion
around that subject matter it clicked
and away we go and he's really kicking
it in right now
v box is really looking on the up I'm
really excited about that company right
now
you know what I'm gonna throw a right
hook link it up d-roc what's up Gary
it's been a minute listen I want to talk
about being selfish how do you best make
decisions in your own interest even
though they might negatively affect
people around you that's family business
personal friends anything let me know
you know how long I've known this kid I
think there there may be a video of him
actually being on Wine Library TV like
eight nine years ago I had played again
Jackson
how do you best make decisions in your
own interest business personal friends a
great question great great great great
great question Jackson there's an
interesting part of your question I
truly don't think that when I'm being
selfish it's coming at the detriment of
somebody else and so that's how I handle
it you know in those I mean I think I'm
always selfish and never selfish like
it's just I'm living I'm living and so
you know the way I justify it a lot of
times is I feel like when I'm in my most
selfish place it's that I'm doing
something that optically looks selfish
for me in the short term but it's
actually gonna positively affect the
people in the long term and that I'm
making a decision that I think I'm right
in a five-year window versus a
five-month window and that history will
allow that person to feel that it was
palpable when they rekindle and their
thoughts around it even though it might
sting or not feel as great in the
short-term crap I really you know what
putting Jackson fall well you did the
right foot it's really not that hard to
Google is putting Jackson fall wine
library jacob asks if you could only
make one post and then not be able to
post again for another year on any
platform what would your post be
that's a great question who's this from
Jacob - things went through my mind fast
literally you know I think fast
so as India's asking the question I was
like okay first one was gonna say I love
you and then the second one if this is
really this maybe the quote you know
what we need to really think about this
this might be the question that most
sums me up as you asked that question
the first reaction was I love you
the second reaction is what
call-to-action do I want which is like
buy my book or like download my show or
I'll promise I'll be back so sign up for
my email newsletter
it was literally literally literally
literally the two most polar opposite
thoughts and that my friends sums it up
that's insane because that was literally
the two things but you know what makes
me feel good now that I rewind this I
thought I love you first before and then
I something I'm 15 I still think I'm 51%
good guy oh you're real growth hacker
Steve on win' a question of the day what
would be the one thing you would post on
a social networks and all your social
network said was the only thing you
could say for a year you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
cool yeah oh you know what real quick I
know you're gray and now we're back to
black one real quick before we before we
close this show out if you're still with
me
do we have all the information for
episode 100 down is like we're feeling
tight is everybody feeling good yeah
like people couple people pink the
four-year-old kid is coming right Ehsan
say right ASA Oh a sense or a son right
because it's Jason got it with it right
Aysen everything else is good yeah
everything else feeling solid the
Facebook
see you Monday